dans la ville de mont tremblant il met
courant de rencontrer des cerfs de
virginie dans les rues et sur les
terrains des résidents juste pour le
mois d'avril 2010 9 environ 20 était une
intervention qui ont été liés à des
chevreuils soit des accidents au soin
des postes qui ont tout simplement
aperçu une carcasses de chevreuils sur
la bordure de la route alors vraiment on
veut cv pour éviter de se ramasser avec
une problématique de chevreuil dans le
périmètre urbain qui irait dans le fond
en grandissant plutôt qu'à dix minutes
il y a trois ans la ville a mené une
importante campagne de sensibilisation
auprès des citoyens et visiteurs pour
qu'ils cessent de nourrir les cerfs je
vous dirais qu'à 75 pour ça il ya une
diminution de mangeoires sur le
territoire ils ont donc y rester un
petit 25 pour ça le conseil a décidé
qu'en 2018 soit trois ans plus tard
après la campagne de sensibilisation de
mettre en place un règlement pour la
toute première fois le règlement
municipal sera appliquée faut connaître
savons aussi que ces 100 dollars
d'amendé si on contrevient à cette
réglementation là est d'ailleurs le 8
mai dernier le jeune policière qui a
constaté d'une mangeoire spécifiquement
fait pour attirer les chevreuils donc un
constat d'infraction le tout premier
long en vertu de cette réglementation là
qui va traiter me les policiers invitent
les citoyens à dénoncer les gens qui
nourrissent les serres il se promène
partout dans les rues puis emmené c'est
que ils veulent rester ici puis ici ben
c'est certes et comme on dit en eux qui
nourrissent mais ils savent pas parce
qu'ici ça vient de partout d'allemand ou
dessous animaux la nature elle n'a trahi
pas les lourds et on sait pas de côté le
russe
ça peut être jugé la ville souhaite que
ce premier constat va servir d'exemple
aux gens qui seraient tentés de
contrevenir aux règlements
vu que les gens nourrissent les cerfs de
virginie
parce que c'est néfaste autant pour
l'animal parce que la nourriture est pas
adapté ce qu'on lui donne et c'est
vraiment pas adapté à son système
digestif
la municipalité espère maintenant que
les serres délaisseront tranquillement
les rues les aides sèvres et les fleurs
pour retourner dans leur habitat naturel
il si karen bastien a du canada dans la
ville de mont-tremblant